today we have the opportunity to revisit
and check with filmmaker Mike Dion and
where we want to start today is man if
you if you go to reveal the path calm if
you watch this trailer that his latest
film it's just like some thoughts of
these lectures aren't fair like so some
people should not be or babe work this
beautiful it's like a religious
experience yeah you know Mike how
proverbs how proud are you of reveal the
path it's I'm very proud it's it's been
fantastic to kind of get to get to that
point and thank you for for the kind
words on on the trailer it's definitely
you know the trailers obviously that one
of the main things that people are going
to see about the film and get a feel for
it and a taste of of the flavor and in
this in this era of being able to embed
trailers and they go they go everywhere
that's really your advertisement for
your film so thank you appreciate that
and that feels great and it really stems
off of ride to divide and and I like
your shirts by the way so awesome and
yeah it feels great to have really I
guess reveal the path is a bit of a
baton toss from ride the divide the new
film is not a film about an extreme race
or an ultra endurance race but there was
something that we kept getting back from
folks who had seen the first film ride
the divide and there was really
something inspirational that they
commented back to us about how after
watching the film it really sort of
inspired them to to get out and do
something great weather for them it was
starting to commute to work on the on a
bicycle or or do their first hundred
mile mountain bike race or or even go to
get a six-pack of beer their bicycle or
something and that was really great for
us to get that comment get those
comments and feedback that that film
really had a big effect on their course
in life after watching that film they
started doing something differently
that they may not have done without
watching that film so so the new film
revealed a path I really started taking
that idea of inspiration and aspiration
and we kind of took it to a whole new
level and I can get into it now or if
you've got some specific questions we
can I don't want to talk too long at the
beginning here the comment i had i think
it's so appropriate that you know
because because really you know ride the
divide you know to at least to me it
represents sort of like the impossible
dream almost you know you have the
longest you know cycling race that
exists on the continent in the world i
guess and it's sort of like you know
it's this chasing this impossible dream
you know you know trying to start the
race and finish the race is it just
tests every every part of you and then
that's kind of where we are right now
that this reason you know we want to
sort of reach out and have something to
speak with you because here we are sort
of chasing our own sort of ride the
divider 0 an impossible dream by
releasing our film goodbye promise in a
very unconventional way and so you know
there's sort of the impossible dream
we're going after there and then the
film itself is about you know when is it
time to say goodbye to someone's dreams
so and congratulations by the way on
getting that out there you know the
biggest thing is is taking action with
anything whether it be a huge bike race
or creating a film you know so many
people i think you know god I'd love to
make a film someday I have a great idea
and just taking the action to do it is
you know I guess I know a lot of people
start off making a film but
congratulations on finishing a film and
then that step of getting it out there
and finding an audience and and in most
instances trying to monetize it and make
a make your money back and or a profit
so so you're absolutely right it's it's
following a dream and and taking action
and actually following through to the
end and and and beyond so and what's
also symbolic in ride the divide that's
similar to being a filmmaker is that all
of those writers
that went across the continental divide
we're on their own like they were
responsible right for their own food and
shelter and sometimes they were battling
wildlife or you know human animals of
all sorts that were you know in the in
the wildlife they're out of the you know
the hiking trails and stuff how has it
been for you sort of on your own in that
same symbolic manner where you're sort
of I know you have a great team behind
you Joe Cantwell in hunter weeks yeah
it's it's been a lot easier with reveal
the path for me in particular ride the
divide was my first feature-length
project you mentioned hunter weeks when
we teamed up with ride the divide he had
two prior indeed docks under his belt so
so it's definitely having the audience
that we created with ride the divide the
second film keeping that same audience
and building upon it and not only your
audience but then the distribution
outlets with with digital and and
various other items has made this new
film definitely easier to get out there
because you're not starting from scratch
to to chip away at that particular niche
audience or you or user group if you
will for for your particular style of
film so it's been easier the second
go-round for sure and in again with the
symbolism of a sort of a race you know
you have a cheer section of people oh
yeah you know keep going with why the
divine I'm sure a lot of those people
that were going through the Continental
Divide they don't always have that and
that's very similar to being an indie
filmmaker so how do you kind of keep
yourself going day in and day out
because you know life gets in the way
responsibilities money all of that how
do you kind of be your own cheer section
thank you I it's you need a support
system and in my instance I've got I've
got a wife I have two kids and just
started school this last week so it's
been a lot of time to get them set up
for school and everything but it comes
down to a couple things if you do have
family and friends that are a support
system just a pat on the back you know
gosh we believe in you we you know
you're doing a great job and and then to
you just have to have I think that
ingrained in you just to I guess you
call it grit call it tenacity to just
keep moving forward day after day step
by step and just keep chipping chipping
away at the tasks that need to be done
and the goal that you set up for
yourself it's difficult and you know
you're you're definitely working 12 14
16 hours a day at it but if it's
something that you truly believe in and
and are excited and for me I'll back up
a little bit too you know once you get
to that distribution phase and people
are seeing your product and giving you
that feedback there's the reward it's
it's almost a drug it's you know it's to
get out and you know holding a camera
for me is unlock a shin is is I get a
high off of off of that and just being
out in it and shooting and and sort of
that creative thing but then you go into
the Edit Bay and it's dark and and
you're you're sort of isolated and
you're creating and crafting and then
you kind of get to the distribution and
getting that feedback then there's that
spike again of clapping and applause and
and now a great job so it's it's a
roller coaster and when you're at those
lower depth levels where it doesn't feel
good and it's hard you just gotta keep
pluggin it's me that how it was a
Matthew Lee in some of his sort of
tactics to keep going inspiring you I
know he's now in this other film right
it looked like he was in the trailer
yeah absolutely so the new film revealed
a path we've taken Matthew Lee which was
one of the main characters from ride the
divide and then the other main character
in this new film reveal the path his
name is Kurt ref Schneider and Kurt ref
Schneider completed the tour divided
race the summer we filmed reveal the
path so we we filmed a bit of him up and
bath we weren't really sure how much of
the race would enter this new storyline
but we were with Kurt at the beginning
of the race and speed ahead Kurt
actually won the tour divided race and
then
a week later he was with us starting to
film reveal the past so she was probably
the only person in the world who is one
the longest mountain bike race in the
world and then loaded up his bike and
then went around the world shooting she
do miss film so I guess 22 yes so the
two main characters are these ultra
endurance athletes and and again we
wanted the new film to be a bit of that
aspirational inspirational so we really
dug in a bit and did a lot of you'll
hear a lot of narration about Kurt and
Matthew really talking a lot about what
makes them tick and what inspires them
and what happened in there growing up
and adulthood and how they've crafted
their lives so they can go live this
adventurous lifestyle that that really
feeds their soul so we utilized a lot of
their inner thoughts with the footage
this amazing footage that that we were
able to capture in places like Scotland
and Nepal and Switzerland which is just
amazing so um yeah I guess 22 how's
Matthew Lee sort of kept that
inspiration going we used his inside
thoughts to really portray that along
with the visuals with the new film oh
there's my here's my buddy Sundance you
had to had to make an appearance nice
and so hopefully he's not distracting
back there take a nice little you know
easy state is nestled on that there I
know how much of you do we see in this
film John roll deep play we saw so the
main crew for this was Matthew and Kurt
which I just mentioned and then Hunter
and I were the four main crew now as we
as we take off in Scotland we join up
with a local gentleman by the name of
jazz Hastings which was someone we met
via Twitter of all things and and then
in Alaska we meet up with a bigger group
of cyclists and where we end up cycling
down the coast of Alaska in a bigger
group but the main crew were
four of us and and Hunter and I were
carrying about 20-ish pounds of camera
gear in in backpacks with you know
laptops and batteries so we had really
enough battery and media cards where we
could survive via our equipment in the
backpacks for about 5-6 days on location
with downloading and and everything else
so it was really the four of us and
we've gotten some great feedback from
the film I guess to back up yes so so
hunter and I do make a few appearances
in front of the camera is well just much
like what ride the divide how some of
the the you know the as hunter and
Anthony the main camera crew for that
film did interact and hold conversations
with the people places and things along
the way really to kind of help the story
and and the storyline kind of continued
we kept that same style with this new
film reveal the path and we've gotten
some feedback where people have said in
some of our theatrical screenings work
over your cameraman who who are out
there filming you guys you know she's
you know doing all all of this stuff
which felt great to us because we did
our job where we covered things well
enough and good enough from from our
perspective that people I thought we had
a whole camera crew out there shooting
this so so there you go come on but it
looks beautiful it looks beautiful and
and since you know you know really what
we want to dive in here is like I guess
you know more more in the distribution
side you know so i guess lately you know
we're talking reveal the path can you
share maybe some things that you learned
in distributing ride the divide you know
some things you learned some things you
want to know some say some mistakes you
made and some things you want to improve
upon as you have begun the stupidest in
fact i think you just started releasing
this in june is that right is that when
reveal the path has not become available
absolutely yes so the the distribution
our world premiere was May 31st so and
and then what we did from from that
world premiere on the 31st is we set up
about a 25 city self-produced theatrical
to
and it's been a model that I feel sort
of the sports films with it whether it
be skiing I think really the skiing and
snowboarding films had had set the tone
for for that sort of a theatrical tour
so we really we had that going for us
with ride to divide and we did read the
divide has screened 140 times now or
something and and and that was something
we set up a lot of those screenings we
hired a promoter who set up a lot of
those screenings and then we licensed
the film to bike shops advocacy groups
bicycle clubs who use it as a fundraiser
and set up their own their own
screenings so we kept that same model we
were on the road for about five weeks
and we just did a Western loop we're
here in Colorado so we started in after
our world premiere which was in
Minneapolis and the reason we started in
Minneapolis was our main sponsor salsa
bicycles is based there so that was our
big world premiere kick off with them
and then are we we started like I said
in Colorado and then we dipped down
south to Texas and then Arizona
California on up and then did a big loop
back to Colorado and hit 25 26
theatrical locations in about five weeks
and that really kind of kicked off our
theatrical our buzz and and we could
really got that feedback in the
connection and we I went out with
Dominic freezer who is a musician and he
did with his producing partner said
green an original soundtrack so the
soundtrack to this new film revealed the
path is all original music which was
another fantastic experience to go
through that so Dominic and I were in
the minivan hitting the road so Dominic
would play four or five songs prior to
the Phil we would show the film we had
some great t-shirts and water bottles
and different things to give away after
the show and then some great interaction
with folks talking about their
adventures and and different things so
it was really a lot of fun and and now
that I am back where we're getting our
digital distribution in line we're
trying to get our TV deals
our international deals in place and I
would say that's one thing maybe where I
failed this go-around is it is not
having done a lot of that sort of work a
little bit earlier on because I feel we
generated a lot of this big buzz while
we were on our theatrical tour and now
that I'm home we're going to by the time
we end up on itunes in various other
things it will probably be end of
October by the time we can get out there
but we definitely we had all of our
merchandise DVDs and blu-rays and a few
other things on our website as we were
out there so we're generating sales off
of our website which I think you've if
you're out there generating buzz you
definitely have to have something some
people can buy in ideally in addition to
the DVD I think having a digital
download at that same time is is
beneficial that's something that we did
not have in place so that's something we
definitely could have done better and I
think it comes down to like you said
there's only a handful of people working
working on these things and at the same
time I should mention we actually did
two films this last year reveal the path
and then another film where the
Yellowstone goes is so hunter and I
filmed both those films backed back so
we went around the world filming reveal
the path and we were home for 10 days
and then we started filming where the
Yellowstone goes which is the entire
length of the Yellowstone River 560 some
miles through Montana was another sort
of thoughtful adventure film that we put
together and then once we've shot both
those films we split off and I edited
and put together reveal the path hunter
split off and edited and distribute
where the Yellowstone goes so we that
the core sort of support we had with
ride the divide was split with this way
so we were kind of the the force ended
up splitting it became individual I
think which then even spread things out
a little bit more and made a lot of the
multitasking a singular
task at that point so goodness well well
no I just I just remember a John Reese
and sherry candler just spoke very
highly about how with rather than divide
you made them offense and they always
used as a case study and I know even for
her goodbye promise with when we
screened it I was like oh I want to do
similar to what you know my deal hunter
weeks did an in-joke am well with Roger
divine we try to implement music and all
that and make it intervent um so with
with the other film I'm sorry what were
your plans with that I I missed it's a
it's the running similar course so so um
as I was and Dominique and I were
running the theatrical for reveal the
path hunter weeks and his new bride
Sarah were off doing similar events with
where the Yellowstone goes so what and
so both films were out there
simultaneously oh I see in theatrical
but now we're at the point yes where
we're putting digital in place and
trying to get the the other TV and
international rights sold in and out
there as well you know so along those
lines um you know can and anything you
can share in regards to how you know
eyes are doing this yeah overrun um you
know what sort of what's the feedback in
terms of the numbers coming in for the
DVD sales and then and then beyond that
how are you going to go about getting
the film onto the digital platforms um
you know what which aggregator company
you're going to use to get it on itunes
etc mm-hmm so as far as theatrical goes
it's uh I had support with someone I
used to work with way back when that I
that I had reached out to help
coordinate the the theatrical to our
inner to put those 25 dates in place
consecutively it really is is a lot like
a touring indie band going out on on
tour where maybe you start in Seattle
and then you work your way across the
country and every night you want to be
in that next sort of city and and and
that's really how we put this the app
thought about this theatrical tour is is
like I said that big Western sort of
loops
so and it realistically took two and a
half months to coordinate that tour to
get it the theaters set in place on the
on the on the consecutive nights and all
the contracts and the details and the
theaters that we reached out to were
independent theaters in nature and each
theater works a little bit differently
in that some times we would go out and
have to rent for wall the theater and
then oftentimes it would work on a 50-50
split and we felt a whole lot more
confident doing that with the second
film reveal the path just because of the
success we knew and felt comfortable
ride to divide it drew the audiences and
and we knew that if we connected with a
local bicycle group a couple bicycle
shops or something in each area to help
spread the word aka the street team like
a band would utilize that really is how
it became successful in each location if
you were able to tap and find a local
entity or more than one my daily two or
three in each of of the cities to really
advocate for you put up posters add
events on their facebook page and and
that's how we in as far as we were
generating anywhere from a couple
hundred dollars profit to a few thousand
dollars profit at each location for that
for the theatrical tour and and then I
guess then to the next step the the the
digital so we went with new video for
ride the divide and we had a couple
other aggregators approached us with a
new film reveal the path cinetic film
buff reached out to us and then there's
a specific sports aggregator called
orchard orchard digital they reached out
to us as well and and we looked at all
three of them and we decided to go with
new video because of the relationship
with ride the divide and they were
really in our talks with them and where
the Yellowstone goes Hunter decided to
utilize new video for that as well so
now we've got the three films with the
same aggregator what that
them to do is hopefully what they call a
brick so if you go to iTunes documentary
you'll see four or five kind of buttons
or bricks and one good example I can
think when Gary hust weight released his
third film they created yeah and I say
they had I don't know if it was new
video who had his stuff but you saw the
HUS to wait trilogy sort of button and
then when you clicked on it it had his
three films and then a few other
documentaries that kind of fit that same
style so in inner talks with new video
it was we felt beneficial because of the
marketing that they could put behind
having now three films from the same
filmmakers out there and uh sorry go
ahead Oh any tips you can offer on
getting that 50-50 split with a theater
and we had a tough time with that you
know falling around and I know it's not
an easy thing were there any type of
things that kind of really sold it for
them or they just saw the following yeah
but i'd say if you're trying to do it in
la la is impossible we found to do to
get any any love any support from the
theatrical side of things i think a lot
of the 5050 splits happened in here in
Colorado Arizona the loft cinema did a
lot of some of that for so I think it's
gonna la is such a film centric place
that I think la you're just gonna have
to go for wallet and you know that's
coming from a guy who lives in in
Colorado anyway but but it's really
getting on the phone and just and I
think because we could send theater
owners to ride the divides website and
look at the past screenings that we had
generated from there and we've left that
up on the website just so people could
see so again it was easier the second
time around being able to convince
theaters to to bring on the film and to
do that 50-50 split and then in some
cities we didn't want to do a 50-50
split split just because we knew in
Arizona ride the divide generated 300
and 500 people or something like that so
we knew it was better for us to go ahead
and
the theater and then because we knew
we'd make it realistically more from a
ticket sales but to get that 50-50 split
from the theaters it's really getting on
the phone and if you can prove an
audience and or hey we've got a
newsletter list or we've partnered with
you know this particular group or entity
the filmmaker user group in this
particular city and and they're gonna
help spread the word or put another
newsletter list so it's some kind of got
a petition for it prove prove yourself
I'm wondering Micah minutes on it sounds
really exhausting doing this is
essentially I mean was it literally 25
cities in 25 days I'm trying to imagine
how how are you building the momentum
from city to city you know I mean
because it's like it's so hard just to
get the momentum in 141 screening let
alone be promoting and getting people
ready for the one the next night in a
totally different area like I I can't
even imagine you're right it was it was
tough and ideally as before you take off
if you had if you set up those support
systems at before you leave then then
thats that's ideal but you know there
there was some some places and and we
could and we didn't do as good a job
just because yeah as I was out there I
was constantly on the computer thinking
four five six stops up reaching out
sending poster is hitting Facebook you
know sending sending notes to the local
bicycle shop and things like that to say
hey we're coming and you'll spread the
word or here's a poster to kind of set
up there and sometimes it's just like
I'm out of juice bend oregon is gonna
it's gonna be what it's going to be so
just show up and and we'll do our best
and we'll see what happens so it's it's
yeah it's having that support and its
really kind of setting the pieces in
play ahead of time realistically before
you take off because as you're trying to
do it from the road it is exhausting and
so it's it's pulling into starbucks and
slamming some lattes hopping on what
stealing Wi-Fi for an hour
up and back in the car taken off again
so it's a whole other adventure it's
really if you look at it as an adventure
if you stress out that it's got to be
profitable but if you look at it again
I'll use that sort of indie band
mentality if you look at it that you get
some face-to-face contact with people
who have come out to see your thing and
and if you appreciate that and make it a
point to visit with them and hear their
stories that's the reward and then if
you can make money as well even you know
the better you know I you know Karen I
know how difficult it can be to sort of
you know reach out to these outlets
these bicycle shops and it's actually
get them to take action you know it's
one thing to just reach out and sort of
connect with them but then you know what
is sort of that sugary message or that
or that know how do you pitch them to
get results where they want to sort of
get behind you when you're screening
what are you doing to help enable that
to ensure that sure it's always you know
what's in it for them you know if you
pick up the phone you send the email hey
I'm doing this I've got this you know
it's you got to think about it what's in
it for the person you're reaching out to
and when we went out there we had a few
things that we would you know how it
benefitted that that particular person
or group or shop in that salsa again our
main sponsor salsa bicycles so the
dealers that repped those particular
bicycles we would say hey bring two
three four of your salsa bikes to the
location will set them up in the lobby
if you want to give away coupons if you
want to give away water bottles if you
want to hand out information about your
shop please come you know will we want
to create and again you mentioned care
an event how can we make it more not
just about us but more about the the
community and and cyclists getting
together and having a good time so so
that's one thing that we really felt was
a benefit to the bike shop and then if
we were we knew there was a strong
advocacy group and like trail building
we would bring them in and and we would
sometimes we gave twenty percent of
ticket sales to an advocacy group in
that in exchange but for four I guess in
exchange but for putting the word out
there and putting up posters and
emailing their particular group so so it
was a bit you I think you got to think
of it yeah what's in it for the people
you are reaching out to to help you
spread the word and and fill theaters
yes I think I got a look at it yeah and
I like to how your if you want to call
it niche your demographic for your films
are all very active people and they're
very passionate you know they enjoy life
they like being outdoors and so I think
that also helps don't you think that
helps spread the message because they're
they're sort of carriers in a way and I
think that's a great and they're very
seems like some of them I mean they
enjoy being part of a community although
i'm sure they like being by themselves
riding a bike but i think that's great
we were talking yesterday about how how
can we find a film that would go to like
six year old golfers that used to be a
beauty on managers you know and that's
where they would have money to buy a
film that's great to that you're your
niche and it's it's it's not improbably
you design it that way it's just what
you're passionate about filming yeah and
and and it not only my passionate about
filming that but i'm a passionate
cyclist myself and have Benson since I
was a kid racing BMX so I feel very
grateful and that that those sort of
those two passions that have aligned the
the cycling I guess even even threefold
the cycling the filmmaking and even the
messaging of of that inspirational
message and kind of doing good and and
feel like you're you're doing you the
message your film is putting out there a
bit of aspiration inspiration and
positive lives and folks too so those
three things coming together it's a
trifecta of awesomeness that was a great
i remember our r le screening with um we
did it with zach and kevin and it was a
great time and I just remember the
energy and everybody was pompton and it
was just a really feel good event you
know it was
yeah yeah I loved it ya know where I
almost feel like I need to watch ride
the divide right now me too I need some
that inspiration and aspiration and
first bridge you know Michael I'm just
wondering um you know have you been able
to take a look at all what we've done so
far with goodbyes promise without with
our IndieGoGo release just just just
curious yeah I caught it a when I when I
supported it what was that week ago
maybe last weekend and I and again the
just sort of following the Twitter's and
and come across it and I was like oh
that's interesting and and and i think
as filmmakers independently distributing
your stuff anytime something comes on
your radar you want to click on it and
see see what's going on so yes i was
able to dig into it and i even watched a
couple of the videos like this that you
did with Gregory and and I'm forgetting
the gentleman's name that distribute oh
adam attack i'm adam after the sorry
about that Adam so I watched I watched a
couple of those and and yeah really just
sort of dug into it and loved how taking
that digital approach utilizing that the
crowdfunding was was new and unique and
and utilizing so your cost to do
something like that was was 0 from
writing a check or having to lay down a
credit card i'm assuming utilized
youtube and the indiegogo platform so
there was really no out-of-pocket costs
for you and then even from a reward
perspective you weren't giving away dvds
or t-shirts that you would have then had
to print and purchase so I think that is
a great way to get your thing out there
whether it be a film or music or
whatever in that in that fashion and a
great way to build buzz and and yeah I
know you had put links from from people
who had reviewed it and talked about it
a great buzz building
from a PR perspective and then my
question is how how do you capitalize on
that buzz to to take it to the next
level and is there a way to capture you
put it out there from a digital YouTube
perspective but now is there something
about it that people would want to spend
more on whether it be I don't know a
t-shirt or and again producing a
thousand DVDs is a cost that that is
tough to do or maybe not even worth
doing but from the feedback and and is
there now you have you acquired enough
emails from a list that you can then use
as a strategy to and I may be going off
and something you didn't want to kind of
here but what sparked what sparked me
from that is yeah how do you what do you
do next after doing what you've done
what's next how do you kind of keep keep
that engagement and monetization going
you know so absolutely not it's and
that's what you know as we get into our
holidays right now but that's what we're
looking at you know it's interesting
because no one has taken this approach
before to go straight to a crowdfunding
platform to to release the final product
so we don't know I mean typically with
with crowdfunding campaigns they're sort
of a surge at the end and certainly
we're going to do our best to create a
flurry and and and try to try to get
that search here again and we have no
idea how far will be able to drive it up
and sort of depending on that is going
to it's going to impact on what we'd
like to be able to do I mean we
certainly would like to be able to go
through Adam chap Nick's distribuir as a
way to get it on iTunes getting on some
other large of platforms we'd love to be
able to have enough money come in to
maybe do a limited release DVD on our
side of things and certainly you know
for those that have enjoyed the film and
what I want to really own it and
experience it that way I'm like the
enabling to do that so we'll see I mean
we think we have a bunch of options in
front of us here yeah and that's just
one of those things is you've just got
to you
just got to do it if you know if you've
got this new idea and no one's done it
before well that's great because again
it builds buzz and it builds PR and and
more people become aware of what you set
up and what you're doing and and and
it's great you just got to kind of keep
testing testing and trying and anytime
you test and try again you've reached
more people and your audience has grown
so that's all that's all part of it
that's all that's the game um find
finding audience and letting people know
you exist in and that thing that you've
created getting it out there yeah you
know and that's you know with this
particular film you know we crowd funded
for a couple of years ago and that you
know we didn't have a production budget
to start you know it's literally
describing the camera you know making
the movie and then we raise money for
post-production costs unfortunately you
know the money that we raised which was
a good chunk of money it still wasn't
quite enough to get us all the way
through post-production so you know to
some degree we should have been
sputtering to the finish like trying to
take you know different money that's
coming in and trying to finish the film
and trying to keep life float and so you
know it's all the greats like we're sort
of sputtering just like hey Lissa
started because it's film and that's
where that's where you know attorney
take me go go turning to youtube and not
having to continue to put up money and
just you know start generating money
with zero cost yet we haven't put any
money into marketing yet or anything
like that it's just like we're just
trying to you know get some revenue
coming back in so that we can then have
more options with what we want to do
next yeah and and that's great is is
being able to I think that's I ideal if
is being able to pick up as if you're
constantly swiping the credit card to
market or or to build to create
something that you then have to sell and
it gets tough and it gets stressful
absolutely but you guys have built such
you know a massive sort of audience just
by by doing what you're what you're
doing it's really at no cost marketing
tool just
just be your outlets of radio and in
YouTube and things like that so um
you're there we are fortunate in that
sense and that's that's also part of the
thing that it took that's part of the
reason why I took three years to finish
as well you've been so busy yeah we have
been busy and became addicted to these
shows and and and getting up content and
things like that so um yeah we are
fortunate we do have a platform and even
with that small platform that we do have
it is still not the easiest thing to get
people to click and buy for one dollar
or two dollars you know it's it does
take some some effort yeah and and and I
keep and again I say I'm so grateful
because I think in the particular in my
instance creating these cycling and and
and Hunter you know creating these
outdoor adventure films i think it is
such a passionate group of folks that
that if they're if you're a cyclist or a
fly-fishermen that that you are into
your things so much that yeah you're
going to drop twenty thirty dollars to
watch that at that adventure and see
something about it so i think that's
absolutely one thing we have going for
us is just the particular genre of films
we create works within a great niche a
niche group and i would say from another
film film in perspective I think horror
might have that very strong passionate
following as well so yeah woo yeah I'm
just grateful that we're making films
that people are are hungry for and and
want to consume yeah very cool um any
final thoughts or questions / for Mike
yeah how do you recharge it sounds like
you're very busy when you do to recharge
is that sort of hitting the trail with
your bike and just just having time
alone to sort of reflect it's um it's
tough to recharge sometimes it's it's
taking its taking a nap at two o'clock
in the afternoon which again thankful
that I can do do that and
being in a in a cubicle office
environment with coworkers around my
feet might be tough for something like
that but to recharge I think sometimes
you just you just kind of got let it go
let things go for a day or or half a day
and and just from me you spend time with
the family and go for a hike and and
just kind of do homework and and just
sort of put it'll put it put it aside
for a little bit but it's it's it's kind
of constantly there yeah you're it's
always something my mind is always sort
of clicking and thinking of engagement
so running like right now we're now that
we're have we've sent out all of our
reveal the path Kickstarter rewards and
all of the pre-sales I've shipped out
over this last week and we've included
some postcards and beer coasters that we
had made up so so I just started a
little Facebook contest it's like hey
show us your reveal the path item
whether it be the DVD or a beer coaster
out on your path somewhere and submit
the poster on facebook and and will
randomly pick a grand prize winner and
you'll win an ipad loaded with a bunch
of stuff from both both films that we've
stuck up there so it's as a marketer I
guess I'm as much a marketer as a
filmmaker so my mind is constantly sort
of clicking and thinking and things like
that don't you think that's sort of a
necessary part of it or if someone has a
team member that has that part of the
brain that works is I think from what
I've seen that that where it really
works is they have that creative and
business side and there's that there's
that synergy it just works it is its
engagement engagement word of mouth is
if it's amazing that you say you know
when I take time off and I'm not that
active on Facebook or Twitter or doing
things you can see sales from our
website anyway just sort of take a
little bit of they stall and then as
soon as you keep that engagement going
and again honest
conversational engagement with something
fun that that it picks back back up
again so it's it's very it's very
apparent that if you're actively talking
about it or putting things out there
which is allowing other people to talk
about it it keeps it keeps the project
going and ride the divide is over two
years old now and we're still seeing
sales from ride the divide and from our
bundles and I think another thing we
have going for us with ride the divide
it is a yearly event so every year I
think more people learn about the race
and if you're googling about it they'll
inevitably come across the film I so now
that's another benefit I feel that we've
got going for us which wasn't planned by
any means none of this so much is is
planned but I think if you're aware of
what's going on in and kind of keep
pushing pushing those in your favor its
but yeah it's it's a constant engagement
to keep it alive my thank thank you for
sure for this feedback thank you for
this conversation my last question is um
when is the because we're gonna pass is
it available on DVD now or no it is or
reveal the path is available on our
website reveal the path com we just got
it set up on amazon so you can pick it
up on amazon as well our itunes and
digital deal you should start seeing
reveal the path on itunes end of october
maybe beginning of november rather look
right around that time frame so all
right because i'm just thinking of this
conversation I I have to I have to get a
bundle I have to get ride the divide I
gotta send it to my uncle Richie was
ahead I have to get him i have to get in
these two movies in his eighties right
no he's a nice i say i think he's in a
7000 so nice but he'll be riding into
his 80s yeah he's been riding for well
over that you know for like 20 years now
and it's just you know speaking to you
it's just reminding that I gotta get I
gotta
both of these phones so Mike we thank
you um that this really means a lot to
us and we're just you know you've
inspired us to my walk away from this
conversation this really inspired by
everything you have going on yeah let's
make you guys yeah really appreciate it
and yeah and again it's I think you guys
are inspiring other filmmakers again
just by by doing it and putting it out
there and and taking that chance and
showing that it's possible on all
different levels so right people thank
you Mike reporter we hope to see you in
LA sometime soon very good thank you
looking look forward to that all right
all right